-Yeah!
-Hey. How you doing, man?
-Matt Bomer,
it's always great to see you.
I was just talking to
Maya Rudolph.
I think I still have glue
on my face from doing this.
And we were
talking about Kamala.
And last time you were here,
I made a pitch
that you should play Tom Brady.
And I meant it.
And I was thinking, like,
is there any politician
that you think
you'd be good at playing?
-Well, first of all, I need to
start commissioning you,
because people come up to me
on the street
and think that that's
a real movie.
And they ask for updates about
the Tom Brady biopic.
-It should be
a Tom Brady biopic.
There should be one.
-And I'm like, "Ask Jimmy."
-I'm good at this.
I have an idea.
How about this?
-Yes.
-I think you should do JFK.
-Yeah. I was going to say
it would have to be a Kennedy.
That would be the dream.
-Or JFK Jr.
-I really believe that.
-I love that American dynasty
kind of thing
that they got going on.
That's it.
-I think you could crush it.
-That's it.
Let's put it out there.
-We're going to
put it out there.
I'm telling you, there is
at least four Kennedy movies
in the works, getting ready
right now.
I know for a fact.
-Yeah.
-So, Matt Bomer
would be perfect to play,
really, any of the Kennedys.
-Alright. I'm in. I'm in.
-Alright, I put it out there.
Let me know what happens.
Oh, this is
going to be exciting.
You're quarantining
with your husband
and your three teenage sons.
-Yes.
-You posted this.
I follow your -- You're great on
Instagram, by the way.
-Oh, thanks, man.
-And I love following you.
And one of the things
that you said --
the best things you watched
in quarantine
was the
Beastie Boys documentary.
-Oh.
-That was -- that was great.
Are you -- Were you
a big fan growing up?
-Huge fan.
I mean, I'll never forget --
it's so iconic to me,
when my brother got the
"Licensed to Ill" tape.
-Yeah.
-That's how old I am.
-It was the tape.
-Oh, yeah.
-And I knew how to, like,
turn it around to rewind it
to get right back to
the beginning of the song
on the other side,
because I didn't have
the boom box
that had rewind on it.
-So you fast-forwarded it?
-Remember you used to have to
flip it around and fast-forward?
[ Both laugh ]
-We used to do that.
That's such a great reference.
-Dude, the best.
And they just blew my mind, man.
I mean, I'm still
such a huge fan of Ad-Rock,
and they just -- I was like,
"What is going on
in the world outside of
suburban Texas?"
And Spike Jonze is
one of my favorite filmmakers,
so it was just like
that meme of eating popcorn.
Like, I couldn't get enough.
It could have gone on
for two more hours.
-I love those guys so much.
-Me too.
-I read somewhere that
you used to write songs to them
when you were a little kid.
Do you remember doing this?
-Oh, this is so humbling.
I started writing poetry
when I was 7 or 8.
-Wow.
-And my first poem was called
"Kingdoms in Conflict."
Started with some
light subject matter there.
Just keeping it light.
-7 years old?
"Kingdoms in Conflict."
-And my older brother
actually found it,
which, for me,
was like, obviously,
my biggest nightmare
at that time,
because I was fully expecting
him to just, like, lacerate me.
-Yeah. Read it
in front of everybody.
-As big brothers
are supposed to do.
And he read it
and he was just like, "Wow.
Okay, man."
-"This kid's deep.
Matt's on a different level."
-"This is pretty deep.
Go ahead.
You go do -- You go have your
kingdoms in conflict.
I'll be here with my G.I. Joes
when you're ready.
-Oh, that would be a great song.
-I think it should be
the title of our JFK biopic.
It's going to be
"Kingdoms in Conflict."
-Again, someone is watching
this writing
"Kingdoms in Conflict."
And I can't wait
for you to be in it,
because, honestly,
when you win your Oscar for it,
you have to just -- You don't
even have to say my name.
You don't even
have to say my name.
Just straighten
your bow tie or something.
I'll know it's for me.
-I'll just --
I'm going to just, like,
bring up a picture of you
and just put it
in front of your picture
and walk offstage.
-No. I want you to do that,
and then I'll know
we have this forever, this bond.
And then we'll come on the show.
We'll talk about it.
We'll show this clip.
That's the way it all works.
Last time, I think we talked --
You were talking about
"The Boys in the Band"
on Broadway.
-Yes.
-It was a play
that you guys revived.
And you actually won a Tony.
And you're now in this film.
It's a Netflix film
with the exact same cast.
-Yes.
-Can you set up what it's about?
-Yeah. It's about
this group of eight guys
who all gather together
for a birthday party
at an apartment
in New York in 1968,
just pre-Stonewall.
It's a group of
eight gay friends.
And the arrival of an
unexpected visitor/interloper
sort of throws
the whole night into chaos
and calls all the relationships
with themselves and each other
and society into question.
And, at the same time, it's,
also, I think, really funny.
So it's got a little something
for everybody.
-I loved it.
I thought it was fantastic.
It was well done.
And what a cast, too.
-I love those guys, man.
We had the best time
on Broadway.
We were that cast that, like,
came to the stage door early
to hang out with each other
and hung out afterwards.
We had epic karaoke nights,
where I would get
different glam-rock wigs
for us to wear.
And I think that sense of
ensemble that you kind of earn,
as you know from being on
something like "SNL,"
from doing this show live
eight times a week,
I think we were able to kind of
bring that to the film.
-Yeah. It's good stuff.
I love it so much.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here are Matt Bomer
and Jim Parsons in
"The Boys in the Band."
Take a look at this.
-You in a blue funk
because of the doctor?
-Christ, no.
I was depressed
long before I got there.
-Well, this should pick you up.
I went shopping today and
I bought all sorts of goodies.
Look. Sandalwood soap.
-I feel better already.
-Mm-hmm. Got in here...
Oh, your very own toothbrush,
because I am sick to death
of you using mine.
-How do you think I feel?
-You've had worse things
in your mouth.
Oh, also for you.
Something called Control.
Notice nowhere
is it called hair spray.
Just simply Control
and the words "for man"
written about 37 times
all over the goddamn can.
-It's called butch assurance.
-Well, it's still hair spray,
no matter if they call it Balls.
-Matt Bomer.
"The Boys in the Band" is
streaming right now on Netflix.
I want to hear when
you get this Kennedy script.
I want to hear about
the Tom Brady script.
We have lots of things
to catch up with,
and you're one of our favorites.
Thanks for coming on the show.
I appreciate it, buddy.
-Same, man.
Thank you so much
and thank you for all the laughs
over the past
several months, man.
It's really gotten me
through a lot,
so I really appreciate it.